shout out to squarespace for sponsoring
today's video we will hear more from
them at the end
hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel and that i always get that wrong
next to me right now is maggie
robinson hi maggie hi hello
hi everyone thanks so much for having me
on today of course i'm happy to be here
with you alana so thank you
uh maggie who are you exactly uh
i'm maggie robertson i'm a six foot tall
blonde and living in los angeles
california
and oh and this is baby grosgu very cute
yoda grow
i'm probably going to put it in the
headline and the thumbnail you are lady
d from resident evil 8
i know it is wild but yes i'm lady p
i am lady d so that has definitely been
life changing
did you expect the internet reaction to
lady d
did you see this coming oh no
oh no no my entire journey in this
um game has been one that i characterize
as general cluelessness
had no idea what i was auditioning for
when i was auditioning i
um had just moved to la fresh out of
grad school
i um i did my master's program in
classical acting in
atlanta so i was living in london and
classical acting for those who don't
know it's
just a lot a lot of shakespeare
restoration comedy
and all that good stuff so that's pretty
much my background and that stuff
lights me up i i think when i was
applying to grad school i was like okay
um this this guy's shakespeare he's
pretty cool and he's definitely if i'm
gonna be an actor
that's the hardest thing you could
possibly try to do
yeah so i'm gonna go off and do that and
if i can do shakespeare then i can do
pretty much freaking anything and that's
kind of how i decided to go in that path
but
um what i loved about working on
shakespeare is that
he is very musical i have a music
background i actually started off as a
singer i
didn't even really like acting to begin
with um so
it's interesting in retrospect that the
voice
has kind of been my foundational
building block and that's been the thing
the core thing from the beginning
and now the fact that i've fallen into
voice over the world of voice over is
just so
serendipitous and feels like oh of
course obviously this is where i was
meant to end up this is what i was meant
to be doing
duh um but
yeah what was your question
first i was gonna say you are correct
that uh resident evil
as a franchise probably couldn't be more
different to shakespeare
there's a bit of contrast there i think
uh well there's
contracts there's contrast for sure but
actually i think the
realms of sci-fi and fantasy because
they are also heightened
spaces and shakespeare is all about
these heightened worlds where you're
you're playing kings and queens and okay
well
some countries have those but america
doesn't have those and so that's
you're you're living in these life or
death um circumstances and you're having
to endow these
crazy heightened um experiences
and make them seem real and palatable
and you're using heightened language so
it's all kind of the
operating within these extremes and i
feel that
sci-fi fantasy work especially the
horror genre that's incredibly
heightened
so it's a really fun world to play in
because
you just get to go to all of these
different extremes as an actor and it's
super duper fun
i love shakespeare for the record i have
a shakespeare tattoo huge fan so i can
imagine that would be exhausting
the question though was actually uh
did you expect the internet reaction ah
yes yes that was the question thank you
for keeping me on track um
no i had no clue and here's where we got
off track because i had no idea what i
was
auditioning for um no i had absolutely
no clue i was just
fresh out of grad school had moved to la
in 2019 i actually booked this
job a couple of maybe
six months after i moved to la which is
mind-blowing
um no idea what i had booked i showed up
for the first table read
and that's when i started to question
whether or not this was a big deal
because there was this energy in the air
people are whispering excitedly to each
other about this franchise and i'm just
sitting there
like a sponge trying to soak it all in
and figure out through context clues
like what
is this i think this i kind of think
this might be a big
deal this might be a big deal um so yeah
and then i went home after
that initial table read and i hadn't
received any of my paperwork before that
point and i hadn't received the script
before that point so then i just went
home afterwards and tried to figure out
through context clues
what freaking game i was in and then
figured out that it was resident evil
and my mind was blown
i'm not a gamer myself but even i had
heard of resident evil and so
that's when i started to become aware of
just the
scope of what this project meant the
scope of what i had just booked it's
definitely the biggest thing that i've
booked today
i think our our amazing producer rosanna
sun at the workhouse
she definitely clued in before i did she
kept saying to me she was like maggie
i think this is going to be a fan
favorite i think i think i think the
fans are really going to like her and i
was like
okay sure rosanna that sounds great it's
good if they do it's fine if they don't
i'm just happy to be here like oh my god
um
and then you ended up being probably one
of the most fan favorite characters of
the entire franchise
very yeah very very quickly
and totally unexpectedly yeah and
yeah it was so bizarre doing that in a
in the midst of a pandemic
yeah that's blowing up i'm also still
under nda at that time i can't tell
anyone about
it people are doing creating amazing fan
art and doing cosplays of my character
even before the game is released
i know i can't say anything um how did
that feel
oh that was both exciting and
excruciating because
i was just oh i want to say so bad i
can't wait to
finally be able to tell people about
this it's been a secret that i've kept
for two years
so so what is really what's happening
how did you first see
the uh the reactions to it like did you
look up people's reactions on youtube or
were you seeing it on twitter like how
were you actually
at the point of discovery when everyone
found out who lady d
was hello well i can thank nicole
tompkins for that because she
i think she just started texting me she
plays uh my daughter daniella in the
game
and she just started texting me pictures
she was like by the way you're blowing
up and i was like
really okay um yeah
so that she's she's the reason and thank
god i had her too because at least i had
one person that i could text and be like
oh my god and she already knew
everything so we weren't breaking ndas
and we were just like wow this is crazy
oh my god
back and forth so yeah how do you mocap
someone who's that tall
that's a very interesting question um
i would say you know for me most of the
i'm very tall and i think that's part of
why they
wanted to hire me so that wow
listen i'm an actor i don't know things
but i would imagine that being a taller
person myself
is helpful to the animators when they're
trying to create a massive woman
one of the things that i had to take
into consideration is that when you are
nine
foot six you also are carrying around a
lot more
weight in your body because there's just
so much more of you
and all of that has an effect on your
actual
physical skeleton and the way that you
move your body so i
very consciously tried to
um slow down my movements
and i found that if she was moving too
quickly then
then it didn't look like her weight was
matching up with her height so i really
had to be
i had to focus on stillness i had to
focus on
going slow and also because she is such
a high status character high status
um as an actor the way you play high
status is
you kind of you don't you don't do a lot
of extraneous movements so the low
status characters are the ones that are
flipping out and doing lots of like
crazy stuff that gives away their energy
and gives away their power
high status characters keep it all
here and every movement is specific and
they're not
wasting any energy so that all the power
and all the
they have kind of this aura about them
um
so those are the things that i was
thinking about in order to give her that
sense of grandeur and sense of weight
um literally and and physically uh
yeah i think someone said that she's
like 500 pounds probably
is what the math was jesus it might have
been more it might be wrong
i bet i bet they know people have done
the math this one guy even did the
science of like what would it really
mean
if a nine foot six woman were to step on
you
so you know what are the step on me
comments feel like
you know for the most part they're
hilarious
um it's got to be weird and i've done it
i'm pretty proud of that i'm just going
to run up to it i've contributed that's
fine you know what she is sexy i get it
like she is totally
gorgeous and all of these things she's a
powerful woman
she's a beautiful woman and i think
that's really cool she's not just one
thing she's all of it
um for the most part i would say i don't
i don't know if i paid too too much
attention to all of the
hyper sexualization of the character and
for the most part
the responses that i've been getting
have been overwhelmingly positive and
about the work that i've done as an
actor
which is what it's all about and that's
what i want to talk about anyway so
i have loved the response that i've
gotten from the community and from the
fan base and
and also just as a side note like in
case you can't tell by grogu
i'm also a super nerd and fan myself and
one of the things on my personal
artistic bucket list was to
have fan art made about a character that
i play and to have people cosplay a
character that i play and i had put
those on my bucket list as things you
know
down the line as games that i'll do
maybe they got me and i
a friend of mine sat me down the other
day and she was like maggie
you realize you can check that off your
your artistic bucket list now right and
i was like
oh my god it's so surreal it's so
special and i definitely it's something
that i do not take for granted at all
it's so
it's such an honor to be a part of this
production to have worked with capcom
their team my god is so amazing and
detailed i just did a play through with
nicole the other day of
of castle demitrask and it's so
beautiful it just did such a wonderful
job
yeah i would not be here without capcom
lady do you would not be here without
copcom so
i just hats off to them yeah so outside
of uh
you said powerful uh high-class
character and obviously very heavy
what were your first impressions of her
oh i love her i think my first
impression
the you know the evil character is
always the ones that are the most fun to
play and i
definitely love playing them i think
because i'm tall because i have a more
mature sounding voice
i get to play evil quite a bit and i
enjoy that
um so i loved her from the beginning
what i love about her is that she
has a lot of pride and she is very
graceful and contained but underneath of
all of that
she's really like she's got a burning
fire underneath she's actually super
duper emotional i think she's driven by
her
emotions but she presents this calm
exterior this collected whatever
exterior and i think that that's so fun
to play with that you have kind of an
outer and an inner at play that are in
contrast with each other
what would you say uh with some of the
most challenging things about bringing
her to life
aside from the hype aside from the
height
um well
what i'll guess i'll give little
anecdotes about what it's like being in
the volume doing performance capture
one of the things that i didn't realize
is you're wearing this
headcam and you have a camera literally
in front of your face here so if we were
in a scene the cameras
to do you can't really look at people
and have a conversation in the way that
we are now
and especially for my character with
height one of the things we had to think
about as actors was eye lines
um so if i'm acting in a scene with
someone because i am supposed to be so
much taller than them
i was actually looking down at their hip
height or
knees or something like somewhere around
there is where
i was looking when i was in a scene and
they were looking above my head
so we're doing scenes together and
having dialogue but
going on between us but we're actually
not even looking each other
that's tough um so that was pretty
interesting and then also with the head
cam
you know from moments like when she is
sucking ethan's blood i actually can't
touch his arm i can't get my face on his
arm because there's a head cam in front
of me
so he his arm is here and i'm here and
i'm having to like
mime sucking his blood with a camera in
front of my face
all completely normal natural things you
do everything totally normal being an
actor is so normal
yeah so then going through all of that
and that whole experience what was it
like when you
first saw her or you first saw her in
motion
well i actually was able to first see
her in motion when i was in the volume
what was really cool is they had these
screens
placed in the volume where we could kind
of see live renderings of
what our characters would look like so
that was really helpful for me
obviously i had seen she's so
beautiful and i'm so excited to play her
she has that classic vibe and i loved
cigarette her hat oh my god she's so
fabulous
but it was really helpful for me to be
able to see those live renderings
especially because i was new to this
so even when i wasn't being used in the
scene
if i had a spare moment where nobody was
using the volume i would go out there
and i would walk around
and as i'm walking around in my body you
can see her in the way she's moving in
the space you can see that happening in
real time
so it was helpful for me to figure out
what
qualities of movement really work well
with that animation
and what wasn't really working with the
dress with the thing so
i was able to kind of workshop and
troubleshoot some things before we even
sat down to shoot or able to figure out
oh you know like kind of curvy motions
or she has this really cool hat so maybe
i can investigate
what it's like to look over and under
the brim of the hat
and think about those movements and the
hat helped clue me in because it has
that nice slopey
brim that helped clue me into her
movement quality which is very cyclical
nothing she does is in a straight line
she's always operating in curves
and fluidity about her movements so
i was able to kind of workshop that and
piece it all together it's a fascinating
insight to the stuff that you have to
think about that people
otherwise never think about i don't
think about oh she moves in curves but
of course she does when you say that it
makes perfect sense to me it's just
never worth it i guess she moves yeah
yeah
well that's incredible and i look
forward to seeing you in more video
games because it sounds like that's
pretty likely yay i hope so well
i hope so um but otherwise is there
anything else that you wanted to share
and where can people find you
ooh yes um let's see i am
a bit of an old lady so i'm stumbling my
way through social media but i am
currently on twitter and instagram at
maggie the bard
uh coming up i will be doing some
autograph signings on streamley i've got
a duo signing coming up with uh neil
newborn who plays my brother heisenberg
and we're going to do like a duo sibling
rivalry signing which will be super fun
and he's a blast
so you can tune in for that and you can
check out my
streamly page at i think extremely dot
com slash maggie robertson
so i've got some prints of my own i've
got the neil duo signing and then i've
actually also got
we're doing a house dimitra's trio
signing with me
nicole and becca pruitt um who play my
daughters and then we're also planning
on doing something special for jeanette
to honor her
as well and her contribution to this to
this game
so yeah check it out to all of that
stuff in the description below
uh so anyone can check it out but thank
you for joining us maggie and thank you
so much for bringing lady d to life
oh my gosh thank you it was my pleasure
and i'm so
happy to be here and able to talk to you
about it and meet everyone so thank you
for having me on i appreciate it
squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from which to
create
a website connect with your audience and
generate revenue through gated members
only content
manage your members send email
communications and leverage audience
insights all on one easy to use platform
you can also display posts from your
social profiles on your website and
automatically push website content to
your favorite social media channels
which i've said this before is a
fantastic way to get started for anyone
who's on my channel and wants to get
into games media
this is what i did back in the day
squarespace also has some wonderful
third-party tools that can help you
manage inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping
and ship items across the globe so go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
olana pierce to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or domain